how can i and the people that are
closest to me make a more significant
contribution to our collective live I
think that and in the United States a
question ought to be how can we be a
little less hypocritical if we're going
to talk about the if we talk about two
things peace in the world and
improvement in the environment then for
goodness sakes let's do something about
the carbon emissions we really don't
have to have the cars in the way that we
do and this is another enormous lost
opportunity over the last 50 years we
could have built public transportation
systems in the United States and avoided
this whole crazy mess that we're in now
in the Middle East because a big piece
of it is oil so I think that's the
single most important thing we could
quit talking about these things and
start doing something seriously but
requires a bit of sacrifice and
basically as a society we are not
prepared to do that
you